black panther director ryan coogler will
be developing a new series
set in wakanda on disney plus here are
some stories black panther fans
want to see in it vibranium is the
miraculous metal with sound absorbing
properties that is the basis
of both wakanda's enormous wealth and
its technological wizardry
it's one of the most powerful substances
on the planet
almost all of it is in wakanda and what
little exists outside of it has
already been enough to change the world
cap shield is made out of vibranium
they make visions body out of it
like that the shoot is made out of it
the bulk of it crashed down to earth in
the form of a meteorite
ages ago the local warriors led by a man
named bashinga
fearlessly visited the site and
discovered the material's unique
properties
and set about using it to make weapons
however
the strong radiation from the vibranium
mutated some of the tribesmen into demon
spirits
but shinga drew strength from the
panther god and defeated these menaces
and his strength and leadership united
all of the tribes
and formed wakanda bashinga became the
black panther
creating a dynasty that would last
through the ages
considering that all of the black
panther ancestors are accessible through
the trance-like communion
in the heart-shaped herb ceremony
there's an easy way to bring this
narrative into the modern day
bashing the discovery of vibranium and
the founding of wakanda could be its own
extended story arc
it was built on a mound of the most
valuable metal known to man
they called it the gift vibranium
there is also an opportunity to
introduce a number of new characters and
expand on the origins of each of the
tribes
if vibranium itself is the focus of the
ark the story of how the great mound was
sealed off
protected and mined over the years and
how that affected local politics and
culture
has a lot of possibilities as well the
decision to hide wakanda's advanced
nature from the rest of the world is
another potential story of its
own this never gets old
mbaku was one of the breakout characters
of the black panther movie
the chieftain of the jabari tribe he
challenges
t'challa for the kingship of wakanda in
ritual combat
and loses living in the mountains the
jabari separated themselves
from the other tribes and were generally
hostile
however umbaku comes to t'challa's aid
when killmonger steals the throne and
even becomes a huge part of wakanda's
defense
when thanos invades earth he also has a
pretty good sense of humor
one more word and i will feed you to my
children
i'm kidding we are vegetarians in the
comics
he is a much more sinister figure as he
directly tries to usurp the throne and
betrays t'challa's friendship then he
becomes a full-on super villain taking
on the power of the sacred white gorilla
however he always keeps his jabari
tribesmen in mind
and protects them even while he rejects
the modernization of wakanda
witness the might of the body firsthand
one element from the comics that could
be fruitful for umbaku's story
is the introduction of his cousin
shantae giovanni brown
a jabari native who grew up in america
she dubs herself
queen divine justice and grows up as a
normal american teenager
until she is summoned home to become one
of the new
dora malaji this could all fit into
mbaku's story after the events of
avengers infinity war
did he have a hand in ruling wakanda in
t'challa's absence
what role did the jabari have in the
post-thanos world
fleshing out the jabari society and
history as they adjust
to become a more active part of wakanda
could be an entire story arc of its own
t'challa's father t'chaka was the last
wakandan king to hide how advanced the
nation was from the rest of the world
as advanced as his anti-surveillance
technology was
even he had difficulty keeping out all
invaders
especially when betrayed by one of his
own t'chaka established a worldwide
network of wakandan spies
and operatives and sent his brother
njobu to america
seeing racial injustice in america and
beyond
jobu rejected wakanda's non-interference
policies
and worked with the mercenary ulysses
claw to steal vibranium
njobu compromised the existence of
wakanda in order to get what he wanted
forcing t'chaka's hand as he killed him
t'chaka leaving behind in jobu's son
njidaka aka eric killmonger to be raised
as an orphan was a questionable moral
decision
this raises the question what other
tough decisions did t'chaka make
during his reign how did he shape the
wakanda that t'challa
inherited i'm sure you did what is right
for rotunda
you always do you're a great king baba
that is why you will always
reign tachaka demonstrated that he was
willing to kill a member of his own
family
in order to protect his country so who
else did he have to kill
especially as superheroes and villains
started appearing how aware was t'chaka
of beings like the eternals
how much did he teach t'challa as he was
growing up and how much did he keep
hidden
what was his relationship with his wife
queen ramonda like
there could be a great deal of backstory
established for modern day wakanda as
t'chaka's life is explored
nakia was introduced in black panther as
a spy and t'challa's on-again
off-again lover
hi this was a sharp break from the
comics
where nikiya was one of two dura malaji
but her obsession with t'challa
eventually warped into her becoming the
deadly assassin
malice the nakia of the mcu is a far
nobler soul
but they barely scratched the surface of
her character in the movie
the story arc following nakia's career
undercover would be fascinating
starting with what led her to choose a
career that took her outside wakanda so
often
her desire to make a difference in other
countries by infiltrating
and destroying human trafficking rings
for example revealed her overall goals
i can't be happy here knowing that
there's people out there who have
nothing
what other kinds of missions did she
carry out the idea that she was
especially keen on protecting women and
children worldwide is a fascinating one
because of her willingness to put
herself into compromising situations
another question to answer would be how
and if
she had to make tough ethical decisions
with regard to perhaps pretending to be
part of a corrupt organization
or assassinating its leaders only the
vagus details of her career have been
revealed and this could have direct
relevance to her current life in the mcu
revealing what happened to nakia after
thanos disappeared t'challa and
half of creation for five years would
make for a fascinating story arc
is she still advancing humanitarian
interests as part of a new wakanda
or have hard times made her an
ever-harder person
the story of the lovers ayo and anika
was explored in detail
in the world of wakanda series and it
could easily be adapted for television
both were members of the dura melange
who found themselves rebelling against
the monarchy
anika killed a village chief who was
abusing women but killing him was still
forbidden
anika was sentenced to death io pleaded
to queen ramonda
on anika's behalf and while ramonda was
sympathetic
she chose to follow the law to its
letter ayo frida nica
and they stole high-tech midnight angels
armor fleeing the city
they helped jabari tribes women and
started rooting bandits who were abusing
women
taking in these women they became their
own self-styled dura malaji
they made an alliance with the jabari
and another breakaway group
the people even though their motives
seemed questionable
at the urging of zori they helped defeat
the people's attempt
at overthrowing t'challa in response
t'challa declared wakanda to be a
democracy
remaining king but only in a
representative role
in the wake of the power vacuum of
t'challa being snapped from existence in
the mcu
this is a story that could be adapted
even more readily
a wakanda without the strong influence
of t'challa is one that could lapse
into abuse seeing a story where justice
and freedom butt up against
regimented traditions is one that would
be deeply resonant
and the love story between io and anika
would add another dimension to wakandan
lore
in the comics the hattu sarase also
known as
the dogs of war were the wakandan secret
police
king t'chaka used them extensively to
repel invaders and assassinate political
enemies
across the globe they were led by hunter
the white wolf
who wore armor similar to t'challa's
only
all in white the hattu sarase wore
similar armor and carried heavy ordnance
as soldiers and assassins
hunter was t'challa's adopted brother
king t'chaka
found him as an infant after he was in a
plane crash and raised him as his own
son
being caucasian hunter wasn't fully
accepted by many other wakandans
and he grew up jealous of t'challa the
black panther exiled hunter and the
hatusaraze
when he became king because he had no
interest in using an assassination squad
hunter later went on to on separate
occasions both provide aid to t'challa
and attempt to kill him none of these
characters have been introduced in the
mcu
but it's not much of a leap to introduce
them given the movie t'chaka's
demonstrated willingness to kill
enemies of the state given a
destabilized wakanda
introducing hunter and bringing him out
of exile in an effort to seize power and
bring order could make him a powerful
villain in the wakanda series
like all of the best villains he sees
himself as a hero
like his adopted father he sees himself
as being someone who can make hard
decisions
when no one else can one of the greatest
villains of christopher priest's run on
black panther was dr michael ibben
alhaj achibe a native of wakandan
neighbor
gudaza he was a simple farmer until
rebels from another country came
he nursed them back to health but his
wife fell in love with their leader
they left achibe for dead and thirsting
for vengeance
he made a deal with the devil mephisto
took bloody vengeance
and then went to america and got an
education
at yale achibe had his eye on wakanda
and its resources
and manipulated politics to stoke a
civil war
that forced refugees into wakanda he
manipulated t'challa into going to
america
and tried to take the crown but t'challa
severed achibe's relationship with
mephisto and
beat him of course achibe became even
more unhinged
designing demented death traps for the
panther and talking to a hand puppet
named
daki achibe's twisted sense of humor and
grandiose personality make him a perfect
foil to the cool
calculating black panther like hunter
and the hattu sarase achibe could be a
perfect villain in a destabilized
wakanda
without having to deal with t'challa he
could easily try to become a demented
populist
leader a twisted advisor to whoever's in
power
a cult leader or any number of other
roles
the panther cult and the white gorilla
cult aren't the only religions
in wakanda indeed many of the tribes
worshipped their own gods
sekhmet the lion god was originally an
egyptian deity who tried to establish a
presence in wakanda
unlike the panther god who only appeared
to his priests
the lion god freely appeared before
humans
however her violent nature didn't
exactly make her a popular candidate for
worship
she even attacked t'challa directly in
an attempt to gain the panther gods
secrets but she was defeated the panther
cult was created by the egyptian goddess
bast
other gods such as sobek the crocodile
god
also had their followers in wakanda this
history
of clashing gods could all inspire a
mystical and magical arc on the wakanda
show
as various sects new and old challenge
the panther cult for control of the soul
of wakanda
even if it's in the background the show
should certainly explore the many
religions
represented in this rich and expansive
fictional world
in the comics wakanda and atlantis went
from having a tense coexistence to
outright war king t'chaka allied himself
briefly with prince namor
in a battle against the nazis although
he still kept
wakanda a secret from the rest of the
world
t'chaka knew neymar was a loose cannon
and kept an eye on him
when t'challa became king he nearly got
into a war with atlantis
over a territory that both claimed but
cooler heads prevailed
later in a conflict between the avengers
and x-men
namor turned against his old teammates
and tracked them to wakanda
he used his temporary phoenix force
powers to wipe out much of wakanda
later when shuri was queen of wakanda
she retaliated by destroying atlantis
neymar got revenge by setting thanos on
wakanda
telling him that the wakandans held an
infinity stone
things simply went too far neymar and
atlantis have yet to be introduced in
the mcu
the black panther franchise would be a
great launching point there's even what
one might consider
an allusion to atlantis in avengers
endgame
when okoye refers to an underwater
earthquake near wakanda
do we have a visual how are we handling
it nat
it's an earthquake under the ocean we
handle it
by not handling it namor would make a
powerful anti-hero in the mcu
being a generally noble figure who has
good reason to be angry at the surface
world
easily turning from antagonist to hero
over the course of a single storyline
t'challa's mother queen ramonda was a
somewhat underserved character in black
panther
she was there to see her son named his
king and then traveled to the land of
the jabari in an effort to heal him the
wakanda series could go into much
greater
depth regarding her character how tuned
in was she regarding the activities of
her husband t'chaka
did she approve of him killing his
brother in order to preserve wakandan
secrets
more interesting than that is what
ramona did when both t'challa and shuri
disappeared for five years
okoye took her place as one of the
avengers but what role did ramonda play
in this
was she the default monarch of wakanda
did she have to fend off attempts at the
crown
seeing her have to deal with the hattu
sarase achibe
prince namor and other threats could
reveal a heretofore unseen killer
instinct
in ramonda the show could also spotlight
her own agency as a queen
what was she like growing up how did she
meet t'chaka
and when did they marry what did she do
before that
how does she see wakanda expanding in
the future all these questions
and more are on the table for the
upcoming wakanda series
on disney plus and actions
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one